hello bill my name is Mazda Conley a
huge fan of your works I'm a soon-to-be
senior in high school and like many I do
not know what I want to do with my life
I love physics chemistry just about
every science my question is why did you
pursue engineering and what advice do
you have for someone who can't choose
what they want to do in terms of a
career thanks and keep up the good work
Wesley that's a great question I had
never heard of engineering really till I
got a job at a bike shop now I am a
tinkerer my friends make fun of me I am
shiny object man
I am constantly rewiring things I'm
constantly adjusting this I live in an
apartment building I'm constantly
tweaking little stuff in the building
and the building managers are very nice
about it trying to improve the building
so what I would say is engineers use
science to solve problems and make
things so if you find yourself a
tinkerer
you mentioned chemistry and physics
these are very traditional engineering
disciplines everything in the room where
you're sitting
everything that created this computer
every principle scientific principle
that allowed the creation of these
cameras in this computer came out of
somebody's head and in general that
person was an engineer in general and
people make fun of engineers because
traditionally we were social misfits
that can't get a date and so on but but
people rely on us and so becoming a full
time scientist and it was never really
something I thought of but I worked at a
bike shop there was an older guy there
who was an engineering school and he was
very proud of it and he can talk
continually about strength of materials
the alloys that make up different bike
different parts of the bicycle and I
thought it was cool and so there are two
things that have always charmed me
bicycles and airplanes and that's what
mechanical engineering is and you'll
hear the expression of mech Aero
mechanical air
space and that was my thing and so
looking back though I got to say I might
have been better as an electrical
engineer I spent a lot of time with
wiring and voltages and amperages and
transistors and capacitors I spent a lot
of time that I might have actually been
had a better intuition in that branch
but I'm playing the hand I was dealt so
if you have an interest in tinkering and
I got a suspect in that you do look into
engineering schools and you don't have
to decide right away man go to college
and see what you think you know you
don't just don't beat yourself up you'll
find your way but I am very proud of my
engineering background I have a license
that I keep current and everyday I do
some engineering thing and just about
every day I do some algebra when you man
when you take that much physics that's
sort of fundamental you can get to the
answer quickly math becomes just
intuitive and it's a real it's just a
great skill go for it